du premier ministre désigné de renoncer
à former un gouvernement
en effet le 4 août dernier l'explosion
du port de beyrouth a fait basculer le
liban dans un chaos sans précédent
depuis la fin de la guerre civile
je dois le dire seul l'extraordinaire
force du peuple libanais a permis au
pays
exemple épuisé en colère de préserver
depuis ce qui pouvait encore l'être
la france a été là à ses côtés dès les
premières heures avec fraternité et
bienveillance elle le sera toujours
cette force et cette amitié indéfectible
ont été prises en otages par une classe
politique soumise aux jeux mortifère de
la corruption et de la terreur
les responsabilités sont claires et
établi elles doivent être nommés et nous
devons en tirer toutes les conséquences
le 1er septembre à la résidence des pins
l'ensemble des forces politiques
libanaises avaient pris l'engagement de
former dans les quinze jours qui venait
un gouvernement de mission capable de
mettre en oeuvre une feuille de route
précise de réformes dont le contenu
agréé par la communauté internationale
demeure entièrement valable et
nécessaire
avec un agenda à un mois et à trois mois
ce qui s'est passé durant ces dernières
heures ces derniers jours est au fond
une clarification les forces politiques
libanaises leurs dirigeants
les dirigeants des institutions
libanaises n'ont pas souhaité clairement
résolument explicitement n'ont pas
souhaité respecter l'engagement pris
devant la france et la communauté
internationale
ils ont décidé et je suis contraint d'en
faire le constat cruel pour nous tous un
mois plus tard ils ont décidé de trahir
ses engagements pris je constate que les
autorités les forces politiques
libanaises ont fait le choix de
privilégier leurs intérêts partisans et
individuelle au détriment de l'intérêt
général du pays
je constate qu'ils ont fait ainsi le
choix de livres et le liban au jeu des
puissances étrangères de le condamner au
chaos au lieu de lui permettre de
bénéficier de l'aide internationale dont
le peuple libanais a besoin c'est un
mois qui viennent d'être perdu un mois
pour mener les réformes dont le pays a
besoin
un mois durant lesquels l'aide
internationale n'a pas pu être touchés
et ceci au risque aussi d'une
déstabilisation régionale et de la
disparition du trésor que représente le
liban pour la région et pour le monde
dans ce contexte je salue le sens de
l'intérêt général des forces armées
libanaises qui ont continué à veiller à
la stabilité du pays
un premier ministre je le disais a été
désigné un homme respectable et sincère
qui a fait ce qu'il pouvait dans des
conditions difficiles
les responsables politiques libanais ont
rendu impossible par leurs sombres
manoeuvres la formation d'un
gouvernement de mission capable de mener
à bien les réformes
certains ont d'abord préféré consolider
l'unité de leur camp plutôt que celle
des libanais dans leur ensemble en
négociant entre eux pour mieux piéger
les autres en réintroduisant un critères
confessionnels qui n'était pas agréé par
tous pour la désignation des ministres
comme si la compétence était liée à la
confession
les autres ont cru pouvoir imposer les
choix de leur parti et du hezbollah
dans la formation du gouvernement en
totale contradiction avec les nécessités
du liban et avec les engagements
explicitement pris le 1er septembre
auprès de moi ils n'ont souhaité faire
aucune concession
jusqu'au bout le hezbollah ne peut en
même temps être une armée en guerre
contre israël
une milice déchaînée contre les civils
en syrie est un parti respectable au
liban il ne doit pas se croire plus fort
qu'il ne l'est et c'est à lui de
démontrer qu'ils respectent les libanais
dans leur ensemble ils à ces derniers
jours
clairement montré le contraire je ne
peux que regretter que les plus hautes
autorités du liban se contente de
constater l'échec en ces temps de
responsabilité historique
en somme personne n'a été à la hauteur
des engagements pris le 1er septembre
dernier
tous ont fait le pari du pire dans le
seul but de se sauver eux-mêmes de
sauver les intérêts de leur famille de
leur clan ils n'y parviendront pas à
tous je dis aujourd'hui qu'aucun d'entre
eux ne peut gagner contre les autres je
décide donc de prendre acte de cette
trahison collective et du refus des
responsables libanais de s'engager de
bonne foi dans le contrat que la france
sera proposé le 1er septembre dernier
ils en portent l'entière responsabilité
elle sera lourde ils devront en répondre
devant le peuple libanais à ce peuple
ami et frère je redis aujourd'hui que la
france ne l'abandonnera pas
d'abord parce que la feuille de route du
premier septembre demeurent elle est la
seule option viable
elle est la seule initiative prise sur
le plan national régional et
international
elle demeure donc elle n'est pas retirée
de la table la constituent la
constitution d'un gouvernement de
mission dans les meilleurs délais mais
il appartient maintenant aux
responsables libanais de saisir cette
dernière chance eux mêmes peut-être
enfin
mais au sein de cette feuille de route
les réformes et les actions sont
indispensables pour le peuple libanais
c'est une nécessité en soi c'est aussi
la condition sinequanone et je la
réitérer ici pour que le liban puisse
bénéficier de l'aide internationale dont
il a besoin pour la reconstruction et
pour son avenir
deuxièmement d'ici la fin du mois
d'octobre comme je m'y suis engagée le
1er septembre
nous organiserons avec les nations unies
et l'ensemble de nos partenaires
internationaux
une nouvelle conférence ans suivie de
celle d'une foot pour mobiliser et
amplifier l'aide internationale à
beyrouth et au peuple libanais nous
répondre aux besoins de santé
d'éducation de logement d'alimentation
au bénéfice direct de la population par
le seul truchement des organisations non
gouvernementales de terrain et des
agences des nations unies
cet engagement c'est celui que nous
devons peuple libanais il est
inconditionnelle c'est ce à quoi je me
suis engagé auprès des nations unies et
de toutes les ong qui étaient présentes
le 1er septembre
pour ce qui est appelé par les nations
unies la phase de relèvement précoce
nous veillerons une fois encore au delà
de cette mobilisation à la transparence
et au suivi des aides ainsi apporter
comme nous sommes en train de continuer
à le faire avec les nations unies pour
la première phase troisièmement je
réunirai d'ici 20 jours
l'ensemble des membres du groupe
international de soutien au liban pour
consolider l'unité de la communauté
internationale sur les prochaines étapes
la première sera d'exiger que les
résultats de l' enquête sur les causes
de l'explosion du 4 août soit enfin
établi et rendue publique et que les
responsables soient désignés au delà des
résultats de l' enquête
c'est évidemment les avancées sur la
feuille de route du 1er septembre qui
seront constatés et la réitération de
nos engagements et de nos conditions
collective pour pouvoir aider le liban
nous entrons maintenant dans une
nouvelle phase où les risques sont bien
plus élevées pour le liban comme pour la
région aux autorités libanaises
maintenant d'en décider et d'en répondre
nous avons vu tous les jeux se faire les
institutions ne peuvent être les
spectateurs passifs de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
quant à nous nous en tirerons toutes les
conséquences
à chaque étape est donc en temps voulu
la france restera engagée aux côtés de
ses amis libanais du peuple libanais et
j'adresse ce soir mon indéfectible
soutien et ma profonde amitié à toutes
les libanaises et tous les libanais nous
pensons à vous sans cesse nous sommes là
pour vous et nous ne lâcherons jamais
jamais je vais maintenant répondre à
toutes vos questions
c'est apprendre des questions depuis
beyrouth s'il vous plaît là elle
s'attelle jadis tv monsieur le président
afin de sauver la face vous dites que
l'initiative française continue mais en
réalité nous savons très bien qu'elle
agonise est ce que le fait ce bolloré le
seul perturbateurs ou le club des
anciens chefs de gouvernement a aussi
joué le même rôle
ou tout simplement ils vous aver que
cette trahison libanaise comme vous
l'avait nommé ce n'est que le résultat
du conflit irano américain dont la
france a échoué à faire ouvrir une
brèche
avez vous monsieur le président le
courage de dire voilà j'ai échoué et ce
sont les perturbateurs merci vous savez
si ça peut vous soulager que je dénonce
des échecs je peux le faire
est-ce que ça fait avancer la cause des
libanaises et des libanais non si je
j'allais dans votre sens je laisserai
les choses dirais c'est un échec je m'en
vais je pense que ça n'est pas
l'engagement que j'ai pris pour les
libanaises et pour les libanais
est-ce que je faciliterai les choses non
où sont les responsabilités ce ne sont
pas celles de la france
il ya d'abord les responsabilités au
liban je les ai dit de manière assez
explicite il ya un instant je peux le
faire davantage je pense que saad hariri
a eu tort de rajouter un critères
confessionnels dans l'attribution des
ministères ce qui a d'abord été la
condition qu'il a mises sur la table
avec eux conciliabules de l'ensemble des
anciens premiers ministres sunnites et
que cette condition ne faisait pas
partie de la feuille de route de la
résidence des pins elle a fragilisé le
dispositif et le modus operandi qu'il a
choisi dans les premières semaines a été
une faute oui je constate qu ensuite il
a accepté de faire des concessions
il est revenu sur cet engagement et il a
bougé
nous devons là aussi savoir le
reconnaître et il a renoncé
à cela pour ouvrir le jeu revenir
stricto sensu à ce qui était la feuille
de route il n'y avait pas de conditions
confessionnelles derrière chaque
ministère et ensuite je suis bien obligé
de constater que le parti amal le
hesbollah eux ont décidé explicitement
que rien ne devait changer à chaque
étape ils ont dit nous nommerons nos
ministres vous ne les choisir et pas
même s'il s'agit de shit nous la
nommerons nous et le président berry
d'ailleurs explicitement reconnaissant
que c'était une condition du reste beau
là donc j'ai compris qu'ils décident et
le hezbollah
et j'ai compris que la volonté de amal
et du hezbollah
et c'est ce qui s'est passé ces derniers
jours était de ne faire aucune
concession était de ne pas respecter ce
qu'il m'avait dit explicitement autour
de la table les yeux dans les yeux
oui à un gouvernement de mission oui à
une feuille de route de réformes
est-ce que c'est durable je ne sais pas
la chance leur est offerte de réessayer
personne et c'est la réponse complète
que je fais à votre question
l'échec c'est le leur j'ai le droit de
ne pas le prendre pour moi moi j'ai fait
le maximum de ce que je pouvais mais je
ne vais pas répondre des décisions
cynique des uns et des autres alors
ensuite pardon de ne pas régler le
problème entre l'iran et les états unis
je ne sais qu'il a réglés depuis tant de
décennies
donc oui si vous voulez que je vous dise
je n'ai pas réussi à régler le conflit
entre l'iran et les états unis
je peux vous le dire ce n'est pas faute
d'avoir essayé d'avoir essayé mais est
ce que pour autant on doit tout
abandonner est ce que pour autant je
dois dire au peuple libanais ce soir
nous avons tous échoué et demain matin
nous nous réveillons avec quoi donc je
préfère être explicite transparent les
forces politiques libanaises et leurs
dirigeants n'ont pas pris la mesure
n'ont pas pris la mesure de ce qu était
là près 4 août
ils n'ont pas pris la mesure de la
colère du peuple libanais de la crise
économique sociale et politique profonde
et de la situation internationale
et si certains préfèrent attendre des
échéances incertaine sur le plan
politique aux états unis il se trompe
aussi car chaque jour rend plus
compliquée un accord car chaque jour
rend plus vraisemblable un embrasement
de la rue c'est pourquoi je dis ce soir
très clairement la condamnation de
l'ensemble des responsables politiques
que je fais la réitération de la
proposition française
la mise en responsabilité des dirigeants
libanais au premier chef du président à
urumqi a une responsabilité
institutionnelle sel dans les prochaines
heures de reprendre l'initiative et je
l'espère avec l'ensemble des forces
politiques de réussir à nommer ce
gouvernement de mission
mais les derniers mois nous ont appris
une chose si c'est un gouvernement
politique de gens désignés par les
partis
l'expérience en a été faite les derniers
mois il ne produit pas de résultats il
ne sait pas conduire de réformes
la clé est d'avoir un gouvernement de
mission faisant des réformes à gré eq
santé et d'avancé et donc mon souhait
est que dans les prochains jours
prochaines semaines nous puissions
avancer sur cette base une fois encore
mais je suis obligé de constater l'échec
de cette première tentative qui est
celle du gouvernement a dit mme qui n'a
pas vu le jour
des minutes de france 24
en somme si le président la stratégie de
la france de miser sur un gouvernement
de mission ayant échoué est ce que vous
envisagez des mesures plus strictes
peut-être des sanctions maintenant
contre des dirigeants du balzac ou qu'on
sait proche de la france notamment
vous avez aller au bout de votre
question on le sait on le sait qu'il ya
cette possibilité d'imposer des
sanctions contre différents dirigeants
politiques des différents partis
libanais alors est-ce que vous
l'envisagez aujourd'hui je n'exclus rien
je l' ai déjà dit à plusieurs semaines
est ce que c'est la réponse immédiate
qu'on doit apporter au blocage je ne le
crois pas je pense que ça ne servirait à
rien parce que ceux qui ont bloqué
aujourd'hui n'ont rien à faire des
sanctions que la france pourrait mettre
les dénommés ce pas eux qui sont à
sanctionner
je pourrais dire je sanctionne tout
autour ça n'est pas utile donc ce qui
est utile c'est très intéressant de voir
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre proposition et
après quelles sont les options
regardons les est ce que on peut faire
un gouvernement sans les chiites option
qui aurait pu être un moment sur la
table cette option n'est pas réaliste
parce que je constate aujourd'hui la
peur des dirigeants libanais face à une
telle option
parce qu'ils ont peur du hezbollah ils
ont peur de la guerre est ce que moi je
suis depuis paris en situation de les
protéger de dire je vais engager l'armée
française je sais que les nations unis
s'engageront pour les protéger non donc
est ce que je serai responsable à vous
dire on fait ça non deuxième option
c'est de revenir sur un gouvernement
politique et donc cédé aux partis qui
sont autour de la table
ils vont défendre leurs intérêts renommé
leurs copains c'est le gouvernement qui
écarte et coeur en ce moment ça ne
marche pas et donc c'est pas que je
manque d'imagination c'est que tant
qu'il n'y a pas eu et je ne souhaite pas
qu'elle arrive une crise beaucoup plus
profonde ou au liban ou dans la région
nous n'avons d'autre chemin que celui
qui consiste à essayer de regrouper
l'ensemble
en effet des partis derrière une feuille
de route d'avoir un gouvernement de
mission avec des gens qui sont impliqués
sur les réformes et d'essayer de
progresser
donc je crois que la feuille de route y
compris dans la constitution du
gouvernement du 1er septembre demeure
parce que je ne vois pas d'autres
options la seule option qui permettrait
d'avancer
le peuple libanais les réforme
supposerait d'aller vers une crise qui
ne serait pas que politique mais qui ne
ferait courir le risque de la guerre
civile
c'est ça la réalité dans ce contexte là
les sanctions ne me paraissent pas être
le bon instrument
à ce stade je ne les exclut pas un
moment et dans ces cas là nous nous
concerterons avec d'autres et je le
ferai de manière concertée
mais aujourd'hui je pense que ça ne
répond pas aux besoins qui est le nôtre
c'est un besoin qui coup c'est encore de
faire de la pression politique et
d'essayer d'engager chacune et chacun à
prendre maintenant une question du côté
du liban s'il vous plaît
bonsoir c'est résidence les aïds la
haine tilly une explosion dévastatrice
une crise économique sans précédent
une hyperinflation des libanais qui sont
en train de fuir sur les barques de la
mort si toute cette misère et de visites
de votre part n'ont pas poussé les
dirigeants à former un gouvernement de
mission
sur quoi vous misez alors est-ce qu'on
va devoir attendre les élections
présidentielles américaines les
négociations avec l'iran pour pouvoir
débloquer cette impasse et pour sortir
de cet abîme et deuxièmement est ce que
si jamais vous allez avoir recours aux
sanctions est ce que vous pouvez par
exemple gelé les comptes bancaires des
dirigeants politiques et rentre au
peuple libanais l'argent qui a été pillé
merci alors sur le deuxième point c'est
un processus d'abord qui est long qui
dépend du cas par cas
mais comme je les dis ce n'est pas celui
que je privilégie à court terme parce
que je pense que c'est selon ça n'est
pas celui qui est le le plus utile
ensuite je pense très concrètement que
pour rendre au peuple libanais ce à quoi
il est en droit d'aspirer et l'argent
qui lui a échappé
l'audit bancaire l'audit de l'ensemble
des institutions et les mesures qui s'en
suivront sont à coup sûr l'instrument le
plus efficace et ça fait partie de la
feuille de route que nous avons mis sur
la table et ce sur quoi nous devons
engager enfin pour le premier point que
vous avez soulevé
je comprends
très bien ce que vous dites croyez le
j'ai honte j'ai honte pour vos
dirigeants
j'ai honte pour eux
bruno di figaro est ce que on peut avoir
un nouveau gouvernement au liban sans
actes et une nouvelle formule de partage
du pouvoir qui serait elle-même actée
par les acteurs régionaux l'arabie
saoudite l'iran qui a probablement joué
un rôle dans le durcissement de la
position du hezbollah est également les
acteurs internationaux les états unis
qui ont paru d'abord main dans la main
avec vos et ensuite ont impliqué des
sanctions qui n'ont probablement pas
facilité la tâche
votre tâche alors d'abord aujourd'hui
nous nous travaillons dans le une
structure celle qu'on connaît des
accords de taef qui s'est un peu le le
paradoxe dans lequel nous vivons a été
historiquement plutôt construite pour
les sunnites les vient d'être capturé
par les chiites si je devais résumer
l'histoire que nous venons de vivre
est-ce que nous pouvons remettre rebâtir
refonder les équilibres aujourd'hui il
faudra sans doute arriver à cela
simplement il est déjà trop tard c'est
pour ça que je ne veux pas changer de
pied sur cette initiative
c'est que quand je regarde la situation
votre votre collègue qui était la
résidence des pins la très bien décrite
il ya un instant la situation sur le
plan économique financier social dans la
rue est telle que nous ne pouvons nous
n'avons pas le luxe de prendre des mois
pour rebâtir une solution qui jouerait
sur des rééquilibre ou confessionnelle
ou régionaux je ne le crois pas et donc
il faut essayer de bâtir sur la base des
accords existants un chemin qui permet
d'avoir une action utile et donc qui
réduit la place des partis des clans
parce que derrière les accords de taef
il n'y a pas écrit qu'au fond chaque
parti a le droit d'avoir son pré carré
derrière une politique de se servir et
en quelque sorte d'empêcher de faire les
réformes et de prendre l'argent pour lui
il n'y avait pas écrit dans les accords
de taef que c'était un système de
corruption partagé entre les parties et
les confessions c'est ce qu'ils en ont
fait et comme je le disais sur ce
système de corruption où tout le monde
se tient parce que tout le monde à tous
vous avez un système de terreur qui
s'est mis en place et que le hezbollah a
imposé et je le dis avec d'autant plus
de clarté que je leur ai dit à eux et
que comme vous le savez à deux reprises
je les ai mis autour de la table en tant
que force politique mais aujourd'hui ce
système n'avance plus aujourd'hui
quelques dizaines de personnes sont en
train de faire tomber un pays et son
peuple alors je pense qu'il faut essayer
d'avancer sur le plan intérieur et
international sur le plan intérieur
je ne vois pas à court terme dans le
cadre qui est le nôtre de meilleure
solution que celle qui consiste à
réengager le travail sur un gouvernement
de mission et mettre la pression sur
tout le monde et je viens je crois ce
soir de la m de là où je suis et comme
je le peux en étant le plus explicite et
le plus direct possible
je n'ai je ne peux pas me substituer au
président de la république du liban et
aux autres responsables c'est à eux
maintenant de décider d'être à la
hauteur de leur payer de leur histoire
ou pas et ensuite vous avez raison il
faudrait engager les partenaires
régionaux et internationaux
je ne sais pas dire quels rôles l'iran a
joué dans cette période
je suis très prudent je n'ai aucune
preuve
il ya une tension du camp chiite mais ce
qu'elle a été suscitée par un moment
donné le jeu sunnites que je décrivais
tout à l'heure est ce que ce sont des
surréactions qui sont totalement locales
ou qui sont régionales je n'ai pas de
preuve pour le dire vous avez raison de
dire que la politique de sanctions non
concertée et non coordonnée avec nous de
l'administration américaine sur des
dirigeants chiites a sans doute
contribué à tendre le jeu c'est un fait
et donc c'est pour ça aussi que d'ici 20
jours je veux réengager le groupe
international de soutien pour que
l'ensemble des partenaires et tous ceux
que vous avez cités
hormis évidemment l'iran j'aurai une
discussion avec l'iran bilatérales et
bien que l'ensemble des partenaires
régionaux internationaux qui sont avec
nous puisque clarifier la feuille de
route leur stratégie soyons très clairs
sur le sujet du liban il y à delémont il
n'y en a pas trois il ya une ligne qui
je crois est encore celle suivie par la
communauté internationale qui est de
s'engager derrière notre initiative est
la feuille de route il ya une autre
ligne qui peut paraître séduisante et
qui a été par
et par certains qui est ce que
j'appellerais la politique du pire qui
est de dire au fond il faut déclarer
maintenant la guerre aurès bola et donc
il faut que le liban s'effondre avec le
hezbollah pour montrer que tout ça est
impossible j'ai décidé très clairement
de ne pas la suivre
parce que je pense qu'elle est
irresponsable parce que nous avons déjà
vécu des guerre civile au liban et nul
ne sait dire quand elle s'arrête et
parce que nous n'avons pas à faire payer
aux libanais et aux libanais le
sacrifice d'une telle politique
mais des dirigeants de la région comme
certains sont en effet évidemment attiré
par cette voie parce qu'il pense qu'il
est impossible de compromettre avec
l'iran ou avec leur proxy avec ses proxy
pardon et que donc il faut aller vers
une politique du pire je pense qu'il
nous faut à tout prix éviter cette
escalade dans la période
mais ça veut dire aussi que le hezbollah
et l'ensemble des chiites aujourd'hui au
liban sont face à un choix qui est
également historique qui est de savoir
s'ils veulent faire le choix de la
démocratie ou du liban ou si eux mêmes
veulent faire le choix du pire et j'ai
résisté à la voix de certains dans la
région qui voulait la politique du pire
en disant je ne suivrai pas en essayant
de les ré engagé aujourd'hui la question
vraiment elle est dans la main du
président berry et du hezbollah
voulez-vous aujourd'hui la politique du
pire vous vous voulez vous rengagez le
camp chiite dans le camp de la
démocratie et de l'intérêt du liban et
quand je dis que quelque chose peut se
passer en réengageant je me dis
peut-être que dans la conscience
l'esprit de femmes et d'hommes qui sont
libanais et libanaise ils peuvent
décider le bien de leur pays c'est à
dire son sursaut sa survie plutôt que la
fidélité à une puissance étrangère
s'il décide le pire il ya un risque pour
qu'ils créent le pire
alors à court terme politiquement
de toute façon je laisse aujourd'hui les
forces politiques libanaises prêter
entre elles j'ai eu énormément
d'interaction avec tout le monde ces
dernières semaines comme vous le savez
je fais le constat donc le point auquel
on arrive c'était la réponse que je
faisais à votre première collègues là où
je peux vous dire très clairement que je
considère que ce n'est pas l'échec de la
france c'est que nous ne sommes pas des
engagés nous avons fait tout ce que nous
pouvions
et donc je ne prends pas les chèques
l'échec c'est le leur l'irresponsabilité
c'est la leur mais là dans la phase qui
rendent jeudi la feuille de route que
nous avons mis sur la table demeure
notre engagement international et
régional demeure mais je laisse
maintenant les forces politiques
libanaises réinitié sur cette base à y
prendre leurs responsabilités pendant
les jours et les semaines qui viennent
fausse de reprendre une question du côté
du liban
s'il vous plaît
bonsoir monsieur le président zen
antonios de l'orient le jour
vous avez fait face à une trahison de la
part des partis politiques qui n'ont pas
tenu parole après s'être engagé à former
un gouvernement de mission
on craint aujourd'hui de ne plus
bénéficier de l'initiative française si
on continue de la sorte qu'est ce qui
pourrait entraîner la fin de
l'engagement français au liban
aujourd'hui j'ai gelé dit l'initiative
française persiste et notre engagement
mon engagement à l'égard des libanaises
et des libanais est là et ne cessera pas
maintenant je voulais dit qu'allons nous
faire
d'abord sur le plan du soutien de la
reconstruction de de l'aide faire ce que
j'ai dit ça c'est un conditionnel c'est
véritablement le rôle qui doit être le
nôtre avec une nation unie et nos
partenaires internationaux
lever à nouveau de l'aide internationale
pour la santé l'école la reconstruction
durable
le redémarrage économique et s'assurer
du suivi et de la bonne arrivée de cet
argent et ses matériaux aux ong et au
peuple libanais deuxièmement sur le plan
politique interne
je laisse les forces politiques
maintenant réagir essayer d'avoir un
sursaut et prendre conscience de ce qui
s'est passé et je ne veux pas qu'il y
ait d'ambiguïté sur le rôle de la france
ou de complicité
si je puis dire à l'égard de ce que je
considère comme une trahison
une dérive par rapport aux engagements
du 1er septembre pour moi tous les
termes demeurent et c'est la question de
confiance qui est posé sur les semaines
à venir et puis troisièmement sur le
plan international nous nous allons donc
réunir le groupe international de
soutien pour avoir l'accord de tous sur
la feuille de route et pouvoir être sûr
qu'on réengage bien toute la communauté
internationale sur celle ci d'ici
quelques semaines
c'est à dire au fond je pense à
l'horizon environs d'un mois un mois et
demi nous serons obligés de faire le
le bilan de ces avancées interne et
internationale si il n'y a aucune
avancée sur le plan interne alors nous
serons obligés d'envisager une nouvelle
phase de manière très claire et de poser
la question de confiance
est ce qu'un gouvernement de mission sur
la base de la feuille de route est
encore possible
ou est ce qu'il faut à ce moment-là
changé la donne et elle est peut-être
dans une voie plus systémique de
recomposition politique au liban je
pense qu'elle prendrait beaucoup de plus
de temps je pense qu'elle est
aujourd'hui très aventureuse compte tenu
de la situation économique sociale
politique mais peut-être qu'elle nous
sera imposé à ce moment là si je pense
sans doute à ce moment là qu'il nous
faudra voir les choses d'ici quatre à
six semaines
donc voilà comment je peux vous dire des
choses pour moi le mois qui vient est
celui qui permettra en tout cas sur la
base totale de de la feuille de route du
premier septembre d'essayer encore sur
celle ci si nous n'arrivons pas à
progresser sur celle ci il faudra sans
doute pivoter des choses d'ici quatre à
six semaines et voir quels sont les
paramètres qu'on doit bouger ses prisons
vous aviez proposé aux libanais de vous
poser des questions via facebook je vous
propose maintenant de prendre du coup
une question de gamme louche sur
l'avenir du liban
le retour de l'emploi et de l'âge d'or
est il réellement encore possible au
liban je crois que tout est possible
mais rien ne l'est ou plutôt le pire
la seule chose à craindre tant que les
forces politiques se comporteront de
cette manière je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
grande difficulté sur le plan économique
puisque la question est économique
c'est évidemment qu'il faut reconstruire
stabiliser financièrement et rebâtir en
interne et en externe le modèle qui a
fait le succès du liban le plein emploi
le succès du liban dépend de son système
financier
plus qu'aucun autre pays de la région et
que d'ailleurs beaucoup d'autres pays au
monde pourquoi parce que le liban n'a
pas une production domestique qui lui
permet de subvenir à ses besoins et donc
il a structurellement un déficit
commercial réel
il ne peut être qu'on ne peut être
compensée par des flux financiers
entrants et donc une attractivité
financière de la place c'est à dire une
fiabilité de la place financière
libanaise et une solidité de celle ci a
été historiquement
l'âge d'or si je puis dire du modèle
libanais ce modèle aujourd'hui est en
train soyons même plus directe puisque
je le suis depuis le début de notre
échange s'est effondré il s'est effondré
pour quelles raisons d'abord l'absence
de réformes pour que d'ailleurs chacune
et chacun comprenne comment l'âge d'or 7
essoufflé d'abord parce qu'il n'y a pas
eu les réformes politiques et qu'il y à
eut donc secteur après secteur la
corruption l'absence de réformes d'erdf
et de rente qui se sont créés et donc à
un moment donné le pays ne peut plus
créer d'emplois et de richesses parce
que il est capturé par des intérêts
privés
ses intérêts ont été très lié à des
familles et des partis politiques qui
sont encore aujourd'hui en place et en
disant ça je suis extrêmement heureux
cuménique je suis très vite années en
disant ça il ya tout le monde et donc
tous les secteurs ont été
progressivement étouffé par les
profiteurs de ces secteurs
c'est le premier c'est la première chose
qui a enlevé de l'emploi et de la
croissance au peuple libanais ensuite
parce qu'il fallait continuer à faire
avancer le modèle comme les choses c'est
tout fait qu'il n'y avait pas de réforme
que la concurrence n'était pas créer
l'argent a commencé à manquer on a
attiré des flux financiers dans les
banques libanaises
par parenthèse banques qui ont continué
à se créer en grand nombre pour servir
chacun durant les dernières années et
dernières décennies on a attiré de
l'argent en le sur rémunérant et toutes
ces dernières années vous avez vu les
dépôts sur les comptes libanais qui ont
atteint des taux totalement fou où on
assure rémunérer les déposant dans une
forme de schémas de ponzi
c'est à dire insoutenable pour que les
gens continuent à garder leurs dépôts
voir viennent mettre les dépôts qu'ils
avaient à l'étranger au liban pour que
le système financier ne craque pas et
puis il ya eu ensuite au moment des
événements de l'automne 2010 9 une
crispation des contrôles qui se sont
bien parce que l'argent partait en trop
grand nombre
et là manifestement des exactions
importante puisque certains ont pu
sortir leur argent plutôt ceux qui
avaient des entrées politique et qu'ils
ont pu faire leurs jeux avec la banque
centrale
et les autres qui se sont trouvés pris
au piège avec leur argent dans les
banques
soyons clairs plus personne n'a
confiance dans le système financier
libanais aujourd'hui il ne peut pas
remonter tout seul il ne peut pas
remonter avec les mêmes acteurs dans les
banques privées comme dans les banques
publiques comme dans les administrations
c'est pour ça qu'il faut un gouvernement
de mission
est ce que vous voulez faire vos partis
politiques ces dernières semaines
c'était simplement s'assurer que ce soit
les mêmes qui reste aux manettes pour
faire quoi pour continuer à sortir leur
argent a eu du liban est allé le protégé
ailleurs puisque c'est la plupart du
temps ce qu'ils ont fait ces derniers
mois
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé et
ce qu'ils veulent continuer à faire ça
fait insoutenable et donc il n'y aura
pas d'âge d'orques tant que ça continue
et donc la solution qu'on propose c'est
d'abord ce gouvernement de mission pour
quoi faire faire les réformes dire tout
ce qui n'a pas été fait depuis 20 ans
dans l'énergie sur le port contre la
corruption pour les marchés pour que les
choses repartent faire le bilan l'audit
de la banque centrale et des banques
privées pour qu'on regarde qui a fauté
réussir à recréer un système de
confiance et le recapitaliser pour faire
progressivement refonctionner les choses
en même temps que ces réformes seront
unifiées s'y initier pardon c'est
d'injecter une aide internationale
le liban ne s'en sortira pas sans aide
internationale qui sera massive mais
dans un système assez ni sur lequel on a
de la confiance et vous comprenez bien
parce que je vous décris très crûment ce
qui s'est passé que personne ne remettra
de l'argent tant que ceux qui ont mené à
ce système crapuleux pendant des
décennies seront là et tant que le
système sera tenu par les mêmes avec les
mêmes règles
c'est tout simple et c'est exactement la
feuille de route qui est la nôtre donc
l'âge d'or et les possibles parce que le
liban est un pays extraordinaire parce
que les libanaises libre et libanais ont
ce talent ont su la voir et que c'est un
pays ouvert
stratégiquement placés de manière unique
et donc il peut retrouver sa force mais
il a été étouffé par quelques décideurs
par des clans depuis des décennies les
choses s'accéléraient c'est ça qui doit
cesser et au fond soit il y à un sursaut
de tous ceux qui ont fauté mais qui se
dise sinon ça s'effondrera
maintenant soit il n'y a pas de sursaut
et il y aura à ce moment là des chocs
ils viendront de l'extérieur ou de
l'intérieur mais c'est immanquable je
fais tout pour que ça n'arrive pas et
tout pour qu'on puisse accompagner les
choses si la diète mais c'est évident
que le peuple était épuisée par ce
système de corruption est maintenant de
terreur ajouté à la corruption et que
personne n'osera le liban tant qu'ils
fonctionnent ainsi poursuit avec une
question d'un libanais alain dans ce cas
la solution n'est-elle pas un
gouvernement laïc il faut un
gouvernement qui représente l'ensemble
des composantes du liban ce n'est pas
moi qui ai construit les les canons les
règles ni la constitution d'une part ni
les accords qui régissent le
fonctionnement politique d'autre part ni
les coutumes
je pense qu'à des choses qu'on peut
changer et donc je pense que le
gouvernement de mission n'est pas à
proprement parler un gouvernement laïc
mais il va un peu dans votre sens c'est
à dire c'est un gouvernement on dit
l'ensemble des confessions sont
représentés mais ça ne sont pas les
partis qui désignent leurs représentants
mais ce ne sont pas les en quelque sorte
chaque clan qui va défendre son intérêt
dans les ministères c'est pour ça que je
crois à cette formule est ce qu'on peut
dire on a un gouvernement qui n'a aucun
lien avec aucune confession etc
je pense que le système est incapable de
le produire aujourd'hui faut être très
lucide et je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit
une solution par ailleurs tout casser
c'est trop tôt c'est pas à moi d'en
décider
je pense que allant dans ce sens la
seule solution c'est un gouvernement de
mission qui respectueux des équilibres
où chaque communauté confession est
représentée par des dirigeants mais où
ses dirigeants ne sont pas les otages de
leurs propres passent pas leur
confession mais des propre parti et
derrière les partis de ceux qui ont fait
de l'argent durant ces dernières années
et ces dernières décennies
question de rimont test politico
en somme ce président gymnase de
politique ou suse et moi j'ai trois
questions je vais faire vite
vous avez dit que les partis politiques
ont fait le jeu de forces extérieures
call forces extérieures
quel rôle a joué l'arabie saoudite vous
dites que le fait ce volet a mis en
place un système de terreur et que les
parties ont peur aujourd'hui mais en
même temps vous attendez à ce qu'ils
arrivent à établir quelque chose de
nouveau
est-ce que vous abandonnez en fait le
peuple libanais au système de terreur
aujourd'hui
et troisièmement on a l'impression que
vos échéances et vos délais ne font que
s'étendre à beyrouth le 1er septembre
vous avez dit que l'échéance était mi
octobre
aujourd'hui vous dit à partir
d'aujourd'hui ses quatre à six semaines
en fait pourquoi est-ce que c'est pas
juste éminente mi-octobre aujourd'hui en
fait ces femmes 1er octobre c'était un
délai qui était celui où normalement 15
jours de formation du gouvernement un
mois de fonctionnement les premières
réformes étaient là si je tiens une
conférence tel que je l'avais prévu mi
octobre
à ce stade je n'ai pas de gouvernement
et donc on peut la tenir elle durera
cinq minutes on dira il n'y a pas d'
aide qui va au liban
donc c'est d'ailleurs ce que j'ai dit
dans les vingt jours se tiendra mi
octobre c'est ce rendez vous ce rendez
vous du groupe international de soutien
il se tiendra mais il n'aura pas la même
nature que ce que j'ai annoncé à
beyrouth il vous avez raison les
échéances se détendent
parce que les dirigeants libanais ne
sont pas capables de décider dans le
temps sur lequel il s'engage donc
l'engagement qui a été pris devant moi
c'est pas moi qui ai dit ça comme ça au
hasard
j'ai vu pendant plusieurs heures à la
résidence des pins l'ensemble des
dirigeants
j'ai vu avant le président berry le
président aoun j'avais vu le premier
ministre désigné a dit ben
tous s'étaient engagées sur quinze jours
je veux c'est dix quinze jours j'ai dit
après ses quinze jours un mois de
travail s'était engagé sur la feuille de
route
donc on pouvait mi-octobre prétendent
avoir quelque chose ils n'ont pas tenu
leurs engagements
donc
du genre en laissant le délit mais
c'était alors c'est simple
qu'est ce qui se passe sinon c'est à
dire là je fais le constat quinze jours
après il n'y a pas de gouvernement
je jette l'épongé jeudi on arrête tout
vous n'avez pas tenu le délai on arrête
tout débrouillez-vous plus groupe
international de soutien on renonce plus
de feuille de route
je peux vous dire ce qui se passera à ce
moment là où la guerre civile ou le
retour à un gouvernement de profiteurs
pour faire simple c'est à dire où chacun
se tiendra par la barbichette pour se
servir au mieux servir ses intérêts
c'est ça ce qui va se passer
donc je veux tenir à cette troisième
voie alors après elle nous emmène
peut-être vers des choses qu'on ne
connaît pas
j'ai beaucoup d'humilité je ne parle pas
de mon pays je ne parle pas de chose qui
dépendent de moi mais ce que je peux
faire c'est maintenir cette pression
j'ai beaucoup réfléchi durant les 48
dernières heures je pense plus utile de
maintenir cette pression que de
l'abandonner mais je suis unanimement
sévère avec tous les acteurs ensuite
donc c'est en effet il ya un décalage
des délais parce qu'il y a une
incapacité à les respecter du côté
libanais ensuite sur les jeux des forces
extérieures
je dis ça je n'ai pas dit qu'ils avaient
pris leur décision sous la dictée
extérieur je n'ai aucune preuve de cela
je dis simplement qu'à ne pas prendre de
décision les influences extérieures
prennent plus d'importance et que tous
ceux qui veulent déstabiliser le liban
depuis l'extérieur
eh bien on une vie beaucoup plus simple
tant qu'il n'y a pas un gouvernement
clairement établie et d avancer parce
qu'ils vont déstabiliser par le
truchement de leurs intérêts ou leurs
proches
le liban tel qu'il est et on voit
aujourd'hui le jeu de l'iran
le jeu de la turquie le jeu de l'arabie
saoudite se faire et donc je ne dis pas
que quelqu un de ces pays et plus dicter
ce qu'il avait à faire aux dirigeants
j'en ai pas la preuve je n'en ai pas
perçu ni vu les choses
je dis simplement que plus le liban se
manifeste comme incapable de se diriger
lui même plus il laisse la place à
d'autres
et c'est l'autre grande responsabilité
des dirigeants c'est qu'ils laissent
leur pays s'effondrer mais qu'il laisse
en quelque sorte les autres venir se
substituer à lui et pas pour le meilleur
pour le pire sur le système de terreur
non si je j'abandonnerai les libanais un
système de terreur si je faisais
justement bien quinze jours pas respecté
débrouillez vous là je dirais bon
courage
vous êtes dans la main du christ paula
les choses ne changeront pas du jour au
lendemain et au fond les 15 dernières
années sont des années durant lesquelles
progressivement on le sait bien il ya
une forme d'enlisement qui s'est fait la
question qui est fait et je pense que
les choses ne sont pas terminées gérer
engagé le res bola comme force politique
dans la première fois je ne veux pas
aujourd'hui dire qu'il n'y a plus aucun
espoir d'avoir un débouché politique
je dis que ces derniers mois ces
dernières années le hezbollah à
maximiser son poids en jouant sur son
ambiguïté que beaucoup de vos dirigeants
dénoncent c'est à dire une ambiguïté où
il était à la fois milices groupement
terroriste forces politiques je dis
maintenant la question pour les
représentants du hezbollah au parlement
et donc comme force politique c'est de
clarifier leur jeu vous ne pouvez
prétendre être une force politique d'un
pays démocratique en terrorisant par les
armes et vous ne pouvez être autour de
la table durablement si vous ne tenez
pas vos engagements autour de la table
je serais irresponsable à vous dire
qu'ils ont choisi ce jeu là parce que si
je vous disais je suis sûr qu'ils ont
choisi la voie du pire je serais obligé
d'en tirer toutes les conséquences et
donc j'abandonne l'initiative politique
et je vais vers la voie en effet du pire
je pense que la question leur est posée
aujourd'hui est que les prochaines
semaines seront déterminantes à cet
égard c'est aussi pour ça que je pense
que la junte dans dans quatre à six
semaines
on doit voir clair sur ce jeu mais
je vois là je ne partage rien de leur
idéologie de leurs idées je dis juste
ils sont là ça n'est pas moi qui les
imitent c'est pour partie des libanaises
et des libanais qui ont voté pour eux
certains peut-être par peur d'autres
aussi par choix je suis respectueux de
ceux là et ce sont les autres forces
politiques libanaises qui ont en quelque
sorte laissé tout cela de venir et puis
certains qui ont décidé d'être les
otages les restos là de manière
explicite et de ne plus être les
dirigeants de leur propre parti ni même
de l'assemblée nationale mais d'être en
quelque sorte à la main du hezbollah
donc c'est ça la question qui est posée
à tous ses dirigeants
c'est une vraie question je ne mésestime
pas gens mais je n'en mets estime pas
les risques pour eux-mêmes
je le dis avec aussi beaucoup de
sincérité parce qu'on connaît les
données de la politique libanaise mail
aux risques qu'ils font courir au peuple
libanais est aussi un risque vital
récit fielleux
écoutez on n'en est pas là là c'est
toujours toujours pareil dans la geste
sur ce choix parce qu'il est cohérent
avec la ligne qui est partout la mienne
celle de respecter la souveraineté des
peuples et je ne pense pas ça je suis
comme vous l'avez compris je pense que
les sanctions les classifications
terroristes bon d'abord c'est un
instrument de la diplomatie qui au fond
très américain qui a fait limite on l'a
constaté sur beaucoup de têtes
d'opérations qui pour les européens est
à manier est un maniement beaucoup plus
incertain et on le voit quand on parle
de la russie où d'autres et dont l'effet
utile et quand même à évaluer et je ne
parle pas de la côte du liban ensuite je
pense que quand on veut essayer de faire
avancer un pays on doit parler avec
toutes les composantes qui sont
souveraines le hezbollah en fait partie
on tente pas la vraie question qui est
posée elle est posée avec beaucoup de
sincérité par des dirigeants qui étaient
autour de la table à la résidence des
pins et vous la poser à juste titre ce
soir et elle est posée d'abord aurait ce
beau là elle nous sera posée à nous
c'est au fond est il vraiment aussi un
parti politique ou neupro cette île que
d'une logique dictée par l'iran et par
les forces terroristes qui sont les
siennes
je n'ai pas de preuves donc je veux
croire encore il ya eu un durcissement
là qui a produit cet échec
je veux qu'on regarde dans les
prochaines semaines si quelque chose est
possible qui est un réengagement pour
aller sur le gouvernement de mission je
ne suis pas naïf je dis que avant de
tirer des conclusions qui sont profondes
et conséquente en termes d'impact il est
bon de d'avoir été au bout de ce premier
chemin font presque à la fin je vous
propose de prendre une dernière question
du côté de beyrouth
s'il vous plaît
bonsoir monsieur le président c'est
diana scanner de and roll avez-vous des
mondes de demander à l'iran directement
d'exercer des pressions sur ses alliés
pour permettre à l'initiative d'aboutir
ses fins en considérant encore l'a pris
et colis en veut et d'autres codes côté
pensez vous que le moment et pour
élaborer un nouveau pacte national au
liban alors sur la deuxième question qui
a été posée en effet par votre collègue
tout à l'heure en tout cas c'était le
même esprit jouer la question de
monsieur malbrunot jeu peut-être qu'il
faudra en venir là je ne je serai bien
présomptueux de vous dire que ça n'est
pas ce qu'il faut faire c'est sans doute
préférable sur le fond peut-être
faudra-t-il en venir là je pense que la
situation est tellement critique sur le
plan social économique et même
sécuritaire que c'est sans doute un peu
tôt parce que ça prendra des mois à coup
sûr avec aussi un jeu qui est encore
instable
régionalement mais peut-être qu'il
faudra en venir là ça n'est pas la voie
que nous avons dans un moment dans un
premier temps prise c'est une voie de
transition au fond celle d'un
gouvernement de mission avec des
réformes profondes
deuxièmement sur les échanges que j'ai
eus avec le liban j'ai eu un échange
avec le président rohani suit donc à
l'initiative du 1er septembre échanges
durant lequel je lui exposer les termes
l'initiative est ce qu'on comptait que
nous comptions conduire je ne lui ai pas
demandé d'intervenir auprès du hezbollah
par cohérence parce que je considérais
j'ai toujours défendu cette idée qui
consiste à préserver le liban des jeux
de la région je lui ai demandé de ne pas
avoir d'interférence négatifs mais je ne
lui ai pas demandé de se comporter comme
une puissance politique libanaise et
tous les échanges que j'ai eus avec les
voisins de la région ont été pour
exposer notre initiative dans ces termes
en présenter l'importance est plutôt
demandé qu'il n'y ait pas d'interférence
qui viennent la bloquer la gêner
la fragilise voilà ce que j'ai fait je
vais maintenant cette semaine ré engagé
une série de contacts avec les
partenaires pour préparer donc la
réunion du groupe international de
soutien mais aussi pour pouvoir discuter
avec d'autres partenaires de la région
et préparer cette échéance que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure de la deuxième
quinzaine d'octobre durant laquelle on
aura ce point avec le groupe
international de soutien qui
malheureusement ne pourra pas consisté
comme je l'avais dit le 1er septembre à
recevoir les forces politiques
libanaises un gouvernement et faire le
constat des premières réformes mais
faire le point sur la feuille de route
et la situation et les conditions de
notre aide
mais ça me permettra de réengager tout
le monde et d'avoir un échange aussi
avec les autres partenaires de la région
qui ne sont pas dans le groupe
international de soutien
voilà je vais devoir maintenant filet en
tout cas merci beaucoup et je redis
vraiment à chacune et chacun que avec
exigence nous serons aux côtés des
libanaises et des libanais dans la durée
et il croyait bien que je continuerai de
m'engager pleinement et de faire tout ce
que la france peut pour les libanaises
pour les libanais pour le liban merci à
vous merci beaucoup